Yeah, yeah, that's the-
That's what you and I were trying to do with the RNA stuff, right?
Right.
Okay.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Yeah, has it been helpful for you?
Thank you.
[laughs]
Right.
Oh man.
[laughs]
It's confusing.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Ah, man.
It's like it's
losing its mind.
Well, I mean it didn't used to be like that so I...
I don't know, I don't know that it's user error.
It sounds like--
it's just kind of screwing up.
Yeah.
Hmm.
[laughs]
Right.
Yeah, yeah.
[chuckles]
[LAUGH]
Right.
Oh, that's not sustainable.
Huh.
Right.
(laughs)
No, no, no, no, it's fascinating.
I want to hear about all this.
Yeah, sure.
Right.
Got it. Okay.
Bye.
Right.
Okay.
(laughing)
Right, right.
[chuckles]
Yeah.
No, it's true.
I-- the--
The good news that I have for you is I-
have figured out how to really
take chat GPT and using
AI kind of to the next level.
And that's one of the things I wanted to talk to you.
about today.
So I'm going to say off camera just because I'm meeting right now.
If that's.
cool with you. So,
The thing that I have been doing...
is so I subscribe to you, Chachi.
Do you do that by any chance?
Okay.
Right.
Great.
[Laughs]
Yeah, Pro is... So Pro is 200.
a month and plus is 20 a month.
on.
So, I'll make a case for why pre-
pro is worth it. So I am going to
share my screen because it does bear.
showing you.
what I've done with Chad TPT Pro.
rather than working out of
a browser.
window.
I love you.
Thanks for watching!
Why?
I'm so...
What?
[inaudible]
Like it was, like, a lot of people just try to come back and say, "What?"
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you.
We wanted to protect.
[inaudible]
[unintelligible]
Thank you.
[inaudible]
Happy New Year!
and make sure to subscribe to our channel.
*unintelligible*
Thanks for watching. (mumbles)
I will create a space in games.
[inaudible]
Just like asking it to be free.
[ Pause ]
This is my website and I will see you soon.
[inaudible]
Bye!
*unintelligible*
All the best.
Let's put together.
I'll catch you.
Thank you.
(mumbles)
Bye.
Now can you please use the code?
[inaudible]
you can also create a type of work request.
and write a copy of it.
is now fully created.
and subscribe! Bye bye!
So, what about the next one?
SuperPupos is by clicking.
[inaudible]
[INAUDIBLE]
[unintelligible]
[Inaudible]
or a marketing service or a network.
that the structure of the data.
time to describe their life.
It's the problem with you.
[inaudible]
(mumbles)
(muffled talking)
[MUSIC PLAYING]
you have for your business.
[inaudible]
you
This is ultimately a 6,000-4-8-8.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[inaudible]
*unintelligible*
and collaboration with the co-op happening in the future.
[inaudible]
You have a lot of time like you will be right.
If you don't have any questions, please subscribe.
[INAUDIBLE]
[inaudible]
So, this is the most important part.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Two.
Yeah, here we go.
and what it's so, so this is just for example.
Yes.
[unintelligible]
I just want to say I'm afraid it's...
You can guess how you can't hear something again.
[inaudible]
I'll have to stop.
So my strong flag is here.
[unintelligible]
like the right to post. And...
See you.
[inaudible]
[MUSIC]
It has all the time.
[inaudible]
(static)
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry.
[inaudible]
This is the one I want to see.
Hey, please don't forget to subscribe to my channel.
(upbeat music)
For my contact information.
[inaudible]
*unintelligible*
(keyboard clicking)
[inaudible]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC]
(mumbles)
[inaudible]
It's scary, it's scary.
Bye. [INAUDIBLE]
and all my stuff are not the same.
If you want to make a video, please subscribe to my channel.
It is doing it now. It is.
Just don't take me. It's just...
This is what the actual game is.
I still want to talk about the time you have been posting on YouTube.
Right.
(audio cuts out)
(upbeat music)
*unintelligible*
for the next video.
(upbeat music)
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[inaudible]
(upbeat music)
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[inaudible]
(upbeat music)
(tongue clicking)
Yeah.
[inaudible]
(upbeat music)
(static)
(muffled speaking)
(upbeat music)
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[inaudible]
(upbeat music)
As you can see here.
[inaudible]
(upbeat music)
Bye. (upbeat music)
[inaudible]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(upbeat music)
[inaudible]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(muffled speaking)